smoke billows over the kiev skyline as
the russian forces draw closer to
ukraine's capital but their main effort
still hasn't been launched
there is a continuing curfew here until
monday at least
the only people on the street are
ukrainian security forces they're
hunting down russian saboteurs
sky news filmed as men in plain clothes
supported by soldiers arrested two men
in a black suv we don't know why they
were targeted but it illustrates the
tension here
the men were held at gunpoint and
questioned
in recent days rumors have widely
circulated of roving russian agents
attempting to bring terror to the
streets and plotting a route into kiev
for the russian tanks
the city's mayor vitaly klitschko says
it's exactly why the curfew was
introduced
the russians sent some troops small
troops
which actually with some time
we as civilian with weapons snipers and
shootings away and
they want to make terror attack and
to bring the
uh the panic to our city
uh it's a goal it's a girl we
hunting here
of them and we
take this uh some people russians who
are coming to our city
so everyone is indoors and quite often
underground these days
the shelling is particularly bad at
night it's pretty basic filmmaker yuri
is the only person left in his apartment
block now it's a
only one place where i can stay
for safety but it is you feel
yes
he is a ukrainian national but was born
near moscow
he won't leave kiev but he has persuaded
his wife to go to the countryside for
now
this war he says is about protecting
basic human rights
and freedoms
extreme evacuation
uh
backpack now we is free
now
and we don't
give
our freedom
anybody never
until the until we die
and that's why you're staying yes
yes it's just because i wanna be free
i wanna i i wanna live like
like a
normal human in the
country with normal rules
there's a new national obsession in
ukraine right now making molotov
cocktails and it's spread to kiev
ukrainian ministry of defense has issued
instructions on how to put them together
others have been signing up to fight in
their droves
at night the bombing intensifies an oil
terminal hit by russian missiles south
of the capital
it seems inevitable there will be more
missile strikes and fiery skies as this
war grinds on
stuart ramsey sky news kiev